schlüssel schlucker er ist zurück bei
den damen und herren der einzigartige
der allerbeste von als spieler auf
diesem planeten
danke meine damen und herren danke danke
auch an dichter vorne ja wir lieben
freunde er ist zurück lucius von und zu
guttenberg
wir befinden uns heute mal wieder in
fortnight meine lieben zuschauer und
zwar wieder in dem dropped calls also
wir sind ja jetzt im zweiten level ein
paar tagen habe ich ja schon das erste
level super toll gemeistert
ja das lief nicht so gut allerdings
haben wir das erste der will dann zum
ende des videos geschafft und heute
kümmern wir uns um dieses level hier
da sind so ein paar autos da müssen geht
nicht sterben sondern wir müssen es
schaffen durch diese autos irgendwie
durch zu springen bei dem ersten level
war es halt so dass wir zumindest ist
dann ganz links bei dem ersten level
hatten wir den vorteil dass das ganze
auf jeder seite gleich aussah hier
allerdings ich probiere es jetzt einfach
mal von dieser seite hier wieder
reinzuspringen einem hier allerdings ein
bisschen war komplett beschlossen also
von der seite hat es nicht geklappt das
heißt ich probiert jetzt mal von hinten
rechts hier vorne da ist auch alles ok
bin ich bescheuert ja oder bin ich
bisher einfach blind also hier vorne
sieht so aus als ob das ein
das war eine tasse die grad umgefallen
ist
du bleibst da jetzt
leute das kann doch nicht so schwer sein
dieses level hier ich wähle wie bereits
gesagt das ist halt das zweite level das
zweite von gefühlt 40 in dieser map also
wenn man ihm ein bisschen drüber
springen und rum guckt da sieht man da
sind noch ein paar andere level auf
jeden fall das heißt es könnte
eigentlich nicht so schwer sein
ich bin jetzt einfach mal so richtig ein
okay aber hier ist glaube ich wirklich
der gang zu nehmen jetzt mal diese
brille hier ab alter sieht man ja gar
nichts durch also ich glaube dass das
sie schon der richtige weg ist ich
spring jetzt mal hier
oh mein gott da unten geht es durch ich
habe einen plan in meinem gedächtnis
also wieder von hier vorne und du
zwischen diesen schilderte nachbarschaft
es kann doch wirklich nicht so schwer
sein ich muss einfach nur hier um
springen zwischen diesen allen da ist
der weg durch den wir durch müssen
kommen schon luca konzentrier dich hier
durch das ist wirklich das ist der weg
da müssen wir durch aber ich muss daher
erstmal hinkommen ist es offiziell gar
nichts dass ich das auch so locker
nehmen dann wisst ihr was ich auf locker
reimt luca und wisst ihr wie mein
vorteil supported raider code lautet
luca also könnt ihr gerne mal hier und
rechts im itemshop draufklicken und
könnte an luca als support creator code
nutzen möglich wirklich wahnsinnig
freuen
dadurch bezahlt ihr nicht mehr wie bugs
oder geld oder mein gott so eng war ich
noch nicht dran so irgendwie ich noch
nicht dran wenn ihr luca als unterstütze
einen trade und luca dort ein gebt dann
werde ich wir sind richtig eng mit dabei
dann bekomme ich etwas von dem geld ab
was quasi an epic games geht das heißt
wenn ihr euch ins kind kauft für fünf
euro oder so kanal wie viele wie bugs
das sind dann bezahlt ihr auch trotzdem
nur fünf euro aber von den fünf euro die
an epic games gehen bekomme ich 20 war
durch ich glaube ihr habt das prinzip
des support ukrainer kurz verstanden ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr dort
luca eingibt und mich somit ein wenig
unterstützt und dann lade ich auch mehr
fort ein video sowie in ruhigen für alle
beteiligten außer die komplette vorteil
community die sich durch meine videos
glaube ich echt beleidigt fühlt weil ich
mein ich bin halt der allerbeste spieler
und die sind eh schon alle total
neidisch auf mich deswegen habe ich
jetzt auch mal eben schnell das thema
dann clever deinen scheiß lama ist ein
bisschen ein ich habe immer noch die
vermutung das ist wirklich an diesem
clara ist ein bisschen liegt also ich
bin jetzt mal hier runter so ganz ganz
vorsichtig hier um die teile vor
ich habe mich schon dadurch flutschen
sehen aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
wenn ich diesen teil ja auch schon
vergleiche mit dem ersten level mit dem
ersten video was ich in dieser webcast
schmerzt das video das ich vor ein paar
tagen in dieser map hier auf meinem
kanal hochgeladen habe mit dem ersten
level da wusste ich wirklich die ersten
20 minuten überhaupt nicht was da
irgendwie ansatzweise hey das ist doch
nicht deine verdammte ernst jetzt erste
halbe stunde wusste ich wirklich
überhaupt nicht wie ich da vorgehen soll
deswegen sind wir bei diesem level heute
ist auf jeden fall schon mal ein
stückchen weiter
ich muss nur einfach schaffen hier
zwischendurch zu kommen luca ganz locker
einfach mal in den tod springen
ich muss wieder so ein bisschen
runterkommen
[Musik]
ich weiß auf jeden fall mittlerweile wie
man dann etwa vorgehen muss man hier
genauso nicht das ding ist allerdings
ist diese komische klappe da hinten an
diesem container einen noch mal richtig
gefährlich werden
da springe ich jetzt wieder ein bisschen
zu weit das ist echt eine ganze nummer
hier
wenn ich jetzt nicht schaffe dann werde
ich auf jeden fall beim nächsten versuch
wieder meine brille aufsetzen weil die
hat mir echt bisherigen wie man ein
bisschen glück gebracht
[Musik]
der eigentlich auch sequenz von nutzen
burkhard support creator code hätte man
leute er ich muss ich euch einfach mal
ein bisschen anstrengen soll hier vorne
ohne gott nein aber diese brille bringt
schon glück ich trage auch immer beim
sex menschen ziemlich abstoßend hier
vorne durch und jetzt hier runter und
hierdurch das habt ihr gesehen wie das
gelebt hat alltag musst du leider
absetzen ich kann jetzt gar nichts mehr
erkennen weil jetzt auch noch nachts in
fortnight ist cool wie das ruckelt
merkte dass kummer ich gehe ganz langsam
darauf zu und jetzt springe ich erst
runter jetzt hits wie komplett verarscht
es ist ein scheiß ernst vor neid guck
dir das mal an hier
diese hätten das so kommt egal
auch mitrocken ich schaffe das
warum ruckelt es so kann ich wenn ich
wieder aufs spiel beenden klicken dann
muss das erste level noch mal machen das
halte ich nämlich hier gerade vom video
und zwar in meinem letzten fordern wie
die häufig als ersten level geschafft
und jetzt hier zurzeit nicht gespeichert
muss die normale halbe stunde den weg
finden wenn ihr wisst wie man diese map
irgendwie speichern kann also dass ich
beim nächsten mal dann ins dritte level
du warst du dich direkt klar man noch
nicht für baloise falls ihr wisst wie
ich die ganze web wie wetter hält
speichern kann so dass ich beim nächsten
mal nicht noch mal der villa mit 2
machen muss sobald ich level 2 ja auch
psychische cristiano ronaldo nur halt in
beschlüssen was ich nicht verstehe ist
warum ich wohin schon drei vier mal
geschafft habe in diesem komischen
tunnel zu springen und jetzt komme ich
dann nicht mal ansatzweise reihen alter
ist der tunnel überhaupt der richtige
weg aber das war jetzt wirklich die
komplette höhe wenn der gegangen da
durch diesen container gar nicht mal
eine richtige weg wäre um nach unten zu
gelangen also hier zwischendurch hier
durch den container
[Musik]
meine fresse knapp dein bein ein
trotzdem strahlte rechtlichen
nasenbluten wenn das so weitergeht
[Musik]
papagei käfig sauberer
in der klappe ich frag mich mittlerweile
wirklich ob dieser weg der richtige weg
ist aber wenn ich mich hier sonst so
umschaue dann muss man hier durch ich
glaube das ist wirklich der richtige weg
[Musik]
traubenzucker
ja ich schreibe dir dreck in deine
weißen schuhe mahnen anderen
amerikanischen youtuber dieses level
gespielt war es eins zu eins so gemacht
wie ich nur diesen nicht gestorben 2000
jahre später
ich gebe auf ich gebe auch noch steht
wenn dieser run hier jetzt nicht klappen
sollte das ist mein letzter dran ich bin
wirklich also da stand vorher vier
stunden noch eine stunde und elf minuten
bin ich jetzt schon in dieser verdammten
fortnight map hier also mein letzter
dran jetzt meine damen und herren ich
das jetzt nicht schaffen sollte dann
gebe ich hier wirklich der weg der bei
allen amerikanischen speedrun youtube
funktioniert funktioniert nicht mit
meinem fetten skin das kann doch
wirklich nicht wahr sein freunde schaut
euch das nicht wenn ich habe mir den
willen das ganze zu schaffen ich hoffe
doch mittlerweile immer in dieses teilt
aber dann verrät ich da unten ich weiß
nicht ob es hundertprozentig der
richtige weg ist es gibt videos wo leute
von hier irgendwie runterspringen aber
das ist ja dass man muss durch diesen
container durch das ist ja scheiß egal
von welcher seite ich dadurch springer
die klappe lenkt ein jahr immer
irgendwie ab das heißt auch wenn ich von
hier und dann passt sich auch oft
einfach nicht durch mein fett punkt ist
kann doch nicht wahr sein guckt euch das
mal an das ist das zweite level von 10
oder so in diesem dings hier
dann steht dann sterbe ich auf der
platte
das will jetzt war kam der scheiß brille
ich bin wirklich motiviert das ganze
hier zu schaffen und in meinem ersten
teil habe ich mir wirklich gedacht als
ich diese map je gespielt habe vor
einigen tagen in dem video habe ich mir
gedacht das zweite level ist safe
einfacher als das erste aber
[Musik]